it is august 18 2022 and you're watching
the code report one of the most
difficult decisions of a front-end
developer's life is choosing between
front-end ui frameworks because once you
get jumped into a gang it's really hard
to get out but what if there is a way
you could be a part of multiple gangs at
one time without causing a bunch of
complex drama well that's just one of
the amazing things that astro does which
is a tool for building multi-page
applications that just hit version 1.0 a
few days ago i made 100 second video
about it a while ago but it has some
really interesting new features and
deserves a second look at a very high
level it's kind of like a static site
generator that allows you to write
content and markdown using the file
system for routing then renders it all
as a static multi-page application for
templating it has its own language
called astro components which feel very
nice and familiar to the modern front
end developer what's really interesting
though is that you can bring in your
favorite front-end framework like react
spelt vue and so on and it will render
the ui on the server while shipping zero
javascript to the browser javascript is
the main bottleneck for performance
which means with astro you get really
fast page loads while using your
favorite javascript framework or
multiple frameworks at the same time but
you might be wondering how does a
component work if it doesn't have its
javascript with it the answer is it
doesn't it's just static html by default
however if you do need interactivity and
state you can opt into javascript as
needed to add islands of interactivity
to your website from a developer's
perspective astro provides a variety of
directives that determine when to
hydrate or load the javascript for a
component if you want to load it right
away like normal use client load but if
you don't need the component to be
interactive right away you can also use
idle to wait until the browser is just
chilling or visible to wait until the
component comes into the viewport under
the hood astro is using a technique
called partial or selective hydration to
render components in place as opposed to
taking over the entire dom that's a huge
deal when it comes to performance less
javascript to run means faster page
loads and better time to interactive
scores that's awesome but astro can do
many things beyond the typical static
site generator like next.js it can
statically generate dynamic routes by
allowing you to define a git static
paths function however if you don't want
to pre-render all your pages it can also
handle full server-side rendering that
means your pages will be generated at
request time and it's also possible to
have dedicated api routes but with full
ssr it needs to be deployed to a server
and can run on node.js or the edge using
platforms like cloudflare netlife or
cell and so on now as much as i love
astro if you watch my recent video the
one limitation i ran into is that it's
not possible out of the box to do
client-side routing it's different from
something like nexjs that does full
hydration where the client-side router
takes over after the initial page load
with astro you get an entirely new page
for each navigation that could be an
issue if you plan on sharing data or
state between route changes however i
discovered there is a project called
astro spa that addresses this exact
issue although it's not yet a stable
part of the framework i also made a meme
framework to help with this and shout
out to everybody who's contributed to
make that library better if astro does
get the ability to work like a single
page application at some point it would
really become the ultimate framework
because it would cover every single use
case on this flowchart and not only that
but you could use any ui framework you
want at that point it could put an end
to the great javascript framework wars
and we could go back to building apps
and peace and harmony when these rich
companies wage javascript framework war
it's us poor developers who die this has
been the code report thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one